no
bite back from any of the young money
stuff you shared
nah nah
nah i did feel like i did feel like
wayne had kind of like took a shot at me
when he said uh
i could uh
i could flip a j mills to a [ __ ] meek
mill when i first heard it i was like
hold on what that's about but then i
thought about it i was like nah i know
wayne that's not it's not that's not
real i didn't hear this i didn't hear
that bar what was this on one of his new
verses i think it was on his latest
journey put out but then i'm smart
enough to know wayne and it's like
when i thought about it it's like even
if that is what he said
i'm not mad at that like because when
you met me i was like aj mills and you
took me and took me to another level
so
so even and i'm gonna keep it real even
if wayne was to diss me i'm gonna keep
it real
just where i'm at in my life right now
and being like respectful on some [ __ ]
like you gave me like a platform you
like kind of help
re-brand me mm-hmm i don't even think i
would i don't even think i would go back
at him
that's out of respect for him i just
would be like
uh you got that off let's go lighter
blown up man
it's not like you hate me it's not like
you ain't got no love for me no more
right you know what i'm saying so who i
feed into it like that i still speak to
him i just uh
spoke to mack though they shout out the
mac man shout out to gutter